everyone's favorite spider-man is
swinging back into theaters this July
we've discovered a ton of fan theories
about the newest Peter Parker adventure
check out these 10 spider-man far from
home theories that are so crazy they
might be true what just happened we
cannot wait to see what happens in all
the upcoming MCU movies Avengers and
Game is the last film from the
franchise's third phase and sadly a lot
of our favorite characters will no
longer be in the Marvel movies however
one favorite is definitely returning
Peter Parker played by Tom Holland is
reprising his role as spider-man the new
movie is called spider-man far from home
it's the first film to be a part of
Marvel's phase 4 we anticipate seeing a
lot of new faces over the next several
years before we dive into the craziest
fan theories let's take a look at what
we know Peter Parker and his best friend
Ned are on a school trip in Europe we
know that Peter and MJ's love story will
start to develop more we also know that
Ned is dating Betty you go Ned Nick Fury
and Maria Hill are returning for this
movie they recruit Peter to fight the
elementals Jake Gyllenhaal has been cast
as Mysterio an old comic book villain
he's got similar powers to Doctor
Strange and can manipulate time in
reality we also know that spider-man has
two new suits one is an inverted black
and red version of his previous Stark
made ensemble the other is a sleek
all-black suit
we also know that far from home takes
place after endgame in fact it starts
just a few minutes after the story from
endgame is over so we definitely know
that Peter survived that piano snap now
let's take a look at some of the hottest
fan theories about the new spider-man
movie so nice to finally meet you
spider-man
infinity wars never happened it might
seem kind of silly to make a whole movie
then decided never happened right well
marvel has done crazier things but how
on earth are all these people going to
get back Peter Parker Nick Fury and
Maria Hill were all snapped away by
Thanos in infinity Wars but they're all
back in spider-man far from home in the
comics nebula and other characters
managed to get out of the realm where
they all went after disappearing they
tricked a nose out of the time stone and
go back in time they keep him from ever
completing the gauntlet and winning the
war there are lots of theories about how
this could go down in endgame but what
about spider-man the movie starts
immediately after endgame is over they
all seem really happy and cheerful for
just having witnessed the end of half of
the universe maybe they're all just
really happy to be back but would they
really just carry on with a school trip
overseas half the population of the
world disappeared and reappeared a field
trip just seems a little weird Stark his
out fury is in Tony Stark otherwise
known as Iron Man has been Peter
Parker's mentor since Captain America
Civil War he makes his spider suits he
helps him out of trouble
Andy recruits Peter into the Avengers
but Stark is noticeably missing from the
trailer of far from home lots of fans
think that Tony Stark will not survive
the events of endgame poor Peter his
first real father figure might be gone
but Peter is still a teenager and really
new to the superhero life he needs a
mentor intern Nick Fury in the trailer
Nick is the one who gives Peter the new
spider suits you can also see Peter
presenting a giant check to charity from
starts organization but the signature
line says Pepper Potts
Tony's partner why isn't Tony signing
his own checks how will this work if
infinity Wars never really happened
Peter seems really happy despite just
losing his idol we think that Nick will
be a great mentor though he has
recruited almost all of the other
Avengers he tells it like it is but he's
way less funny than Stark
need to keep both eyes do you think that
will be a good mentor for Peter
dart spider-man in the new trailer we
get a glimpse of Peters new black spider
suit sure it might just be a handy suit
for sneaking around at night but what if
it means more than that this theory
might remind you of spider-man 3
starring Tobey Maguire but since it's
all the same comic-book character we
think there's a chance it might be true
in the Tobey Maguire movie Peter meets
the man who ended his Uncle Ben's life
he gets consumed by the desire for
revenge and turns dark in the MCU Peter
has seen some serious evil he just
witnessed Thanos get rid of half of the
universe
he even disappeared and if Tony Stark
really is gone Peter might be extra
angry what if the dark suit represents
Peters dark side
we know that Tom Hollands spider-man is
pretty goofy and happy-go-lucky but
everyone has a dark side is Peter going
to have to deal with his own internal
demons in the new movie we wouldn't be
surprised if that dark suit means a lot
more than just stealth
Uncle Ben is back in the comics in every
other spider-man movie franchise Ben
Parker is a really important character
you've been given a gift bear with great
power comes great responsibility
after Peters parents died then in May
took Peter in they raised him as their
own Peter adored his Uncle Ben when Ben
was attacked by a burglar he passed away
in the comics this is what sparked
Peter's transformation into spider-man
but hardcore spider-man fans noticed
something huge in the MCU movie there is
no Uncle Ben Aunt May is raising Peter
all by herself then is barely even
mentioned why did the MCU get rid of
such an important character well maybe
it's because they plan to bring him back
in the trailer for far from home
Peter packs an old suitcase with the
initials BFP those are his Uncle Ben's
initials if that wasn't important they
probably wouldn't include it in the
trailer we think that Uncle Ben will
play a big role in the new movie maybe
he really isn't alive but his storyline
becomes important but maybe
alive we can't wait to find out more
about the MC use version of Ben we've
got another theory about Uncle Ben so
keep watching to find out aunt make it's
a love story the MCU version of Aunt May
is totally different than any past
versions for one thing she's really
young Tony Stark was totally flirting
with her in homecoming we know Tony and
pepper are soul mates but we would be
lying if we said we didn't ship Stark
and Aunt May a little bit tell me what's
going on just lay it out it's just me
and you in the new trailer we can see
that Aunt May is totally supportive of
Peter as spider-man she's there when he
makes a speech and gives him a high-five
and she makes sure he packed his suit
for his trip the trailer also shows an
adorably awkward scene with happy happy
was Tony Stark's bodyguard he also
helped look after Peter happy flirts
with Aunt May really badly he
complements her dress and seems really
shy they may not seem like the most
obvious couple but Aunt May deserves a
little happiness with happy see what we
did there we totally ship it we can't
wait to see if this love story actually
plays out in the movie Aunt May plus
happy forever the elementals are famous
villains we know that spider-man far
from home will feature elementals these
are some sort of creatures that are
really destructive it's not really clear
whether there are conscious villains or
if they have been made by someone but we
do know that spider-man will face
creatures made of sand water and fire we
also know that Mysterio can fight off
the water one in the comics spider-man
has faced some similar villains they
were known as Sandman hydro-man
and molten man there is also a really
sneaky easter egg in the boat scene
there's a boat labeled a SM - 1 - the
comic amazing spider-man featured
hydro-man in number 2 1 - are we getting
to see three famous villains all in one
movie that's definitely a step up from
fighting just the vulture and spider-man
homecoming plus there's Mysterio he's
another famous spider-man villain in the
trailer he appears to be also fighting
the water elemental there are definitely
a ton of things for Peter to fight on
his summer vacation poor Peter
he just can't catch a break Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please
it's not your up these next two theories
have to do with Mysterio in the trailer
Mysterio appears to have similar powers
to dr. strange a lot of people think
he's mystic he is the same green magical
shield in the comics Mysterio was a
stunt and special effects artist who
turned villain he's able to make
illusions and impersonate people even
spider-man himself but in the MCU he
looks to have some magical abilities if
he is a mystic like dr. strange in Mordo
he would have the ability to alter
reality he also has a cape
just like dr. strange he appears to be
very powerful if he can alter reality he
could make Peter think he's on a school
trip to Europe that would be totally
mind-blowing but he could actually be in
New York
mystics can make the world around them
look like anything they want this could
be some elaborate trick to defeat
spider-man Mysterio is traditionally one
of spider-man's most challenging enemies
we know Jake Gyllenhaal will do an
awesome job as Mysterio
alternate-universe
messing with time and other dimensions
can lead to a lot of trouble and no one
messes with time in reality more than
Thanos we have seen that other realms
are possible in the ant-man movie Scott
Lang goes into the quantum realm in the
comics all of tanis's victims get stuck
in the realm of the soul stone what if
MCU is totally messing with us maybe far
from home doesn't take place right after
endgame it's possible that the entire
spider-man movie is happening in an
alternate universe perhaps Peter is
stuck in the quantum realm this also
means that Mysterio could be the villain
in this other world
he might be creating this new reality
that looks familiar to Peter but really
they're trapped in another dimension
whoa that would be crazy
we don't know how big of a role Mysterio
will play but a lot of fans think he's
creating an alternate reality for Peter
MCU has done really crazy stuff before
we wouldn't put it past them to make
this a big alternate universe story
Captain Marvel makes an appearance
everyone is excited to meet Captain
Marvel and her upcoming movie and we
know that she'll make an appearance in
endgame Marvel has also chosen Captain
Marvel to be the face of MCU for phase 4
it's safe to assume that she's the new
leader of whatever here
are less so will she be in other phase
for movies we think she might show up in
spider-man far from home and here's our
proof in the shot with the sand
elemental Nick is seen shooting at the
monster next to him is a woman but this
doesn't look like his loyal sidekick
Maria hill this woman is blonde unless
we're you dyed her hair after Thanos
snap this woman is definitely not her do
you know who is blond Captain Marvel we
think it would be awesome if she showed
up in spider-man do you think she'll
take on the role of Peters new mentor we
know that she'll be around the Marvel
Cinematic Universe for a while her
appearance hasn't been confirmed yet but
Marvel has kept bigger secrets from us
in the past Mysterio is Uncle Ben
alright let's take a look at everything
we know so far
Mysterio will be in this movie and his
name suggests he's pretty mysterious you
don't want any part of this there is
also the hint that Uncle Ben plays a
part in the movie whether he's alive or
not we don't know for sure but what if
these two important people are actually
the same person
first of all Mysterio appears to be the
same age as Aunt May second he seems
pretty nice to Peter in the trailer he
tells Peter that he doesn't want any
part of fighting the water elemental why
does he seem protective of Peter if he's
a villain also if he has all these crazy
powers he could easily have made Aunt
May believe he was dead that's really
true if he's a mystic dr. strange had to
totally leave his life behind a trained
as a mystic people thought he was dead
maybe the same is true for Mysterio
which of these fan theories do you think
are true what other theories do you have
about spider-man far from home sound off
in the comments below our spidey senses
are telling us that you should subscribe
to the things for more awesome content
we post new videos every day
so we hit that notification bell to be
the first in line for the latest news
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]